je crois qu'il faut regarder la
situation l'avait évoqué la situation
sociale de ce pays
en fait on est un pays qui est
aujourd'hui en crise et qui a de
profonde angoisse est en fait le la
violence elle résulte du fait que vous
savez pas traiter les angoisses et que
le politique depuis vingt ans ne s'est
pas très bien par rapport à la
désindustrialisation
on l'a réaffecter beaucoup d'emplois
dans des activités tertiaires à faible
valeur ajoutée donc à faible
rémunération
on a eu des politiques du logement qui
ont fait que les gens étaient obligé de
s'excentrer donc avec des problèmes de
transport de pouvoir d'achat et donc si
on prend pas en considération que il ya
un vrai problème social dans ce pays et
que l'on joue le tennis m'a d'ailleurs
on le veut le le l'ignorer voir le
mépriser comme ça a été au début dé
gilet jaune et les cas vous avez des
réactions mais vous avez des réactions
qui au départ n'était pas agressive qui
était revendicative
ce qu'il ya c'est qu'on a des forces d'
extrémistes dans ce pays qui procède
avec à sophisme c'est à dire le pouvoir
est forcément violent la police est le
vecteur du pouvoir donc la police est
violente et voilà à partir de ce moment
on fait des amalgames et on ignore
complètement le rôle social
d'accompagnement que peut avoir les
forces de l'ordre plusieurs missions on
les agresse et on les agresse parce que
quelque part c'est une dynamique que qui
est en train de se construire de
déstabilisation de l'ordre républicain
c'est pour ça qu'en tant que citoyen
mais je réagis parce que je crois que ya
le problème de l'organisation des forces
de l'ordre etc
mais il ya aussi un problème social
extrêmement grave et qui ne risque pas
de s'arranger
et donc ça veut dire que le les tensions
entre le pouvoir
la police et les citoyens ils sont
plutôt selon moi devant si on prend pas
des mesures que derrière
[Musique]